at the bank of England for us now so Ed
as expected the bank of England putting
the interest rates up by a quarter of
one percent and interesting what else
they've had to say about the economy
yes it's the 12th successive increase uh
in interest rates from the bank of
England we've never seen quite such a
kind of successive set of increases as
since the bank was made independent in
1997 but this is also partly you get
what their their decision is on interest
rates but you also get a sense of what
they think is going on with the economy
because they also every quarter
announced what is known as their
monetary policy report they look at the
state of the economy and say well how's
it doing so we're also getting a sense
of just how they think things are
looking and here you know there is
actually some quite good news they talk
about upgrading their growth forecasts
by the biggest amount that they have
ever done in the history of the monetary
policy committee now it's worth just
saying they were pretty miserable
beforehand they were talking about the
longest recession that we'd seen in
modern history now they're talking about
what might be considered to be kind of
more or less flatlining growth so
marginally positive they're not
expecting to see any contraction this
year and that's basically what a
recession is when the economy is
shrinking so that's good news the kind
of thing to note is that it's not
bringing us into kind of the feel-good
factor we're not going to see growth
that is anything like what it has been
in previous booms they're talking about
growth with below one percent both this
year next year and the year after so
it's not necessarily something to
celebrate except it's not as bad as it
and at the same time they're talking
about inflation being slightly higher
than previously expected now higher
inflation means there is slightly more
pressure on the bank of England to act
when the bank is doing what it's doing
it's trying to kind of raise interest
rates change interest rates to try and
bring inflation more under control and
inflation is considerably higher than it
previously thought you'll have seen
recently inflation is still above 10
well it does expect it to get down to
around five percent by the end of the
year as Ian was saying just a moment ago
the Prime Minister does have that Target
doesn't he to try to halve inflation by
the end of this year this according to
the bank means he might just about make
it looking at their kind of what's
coming out of their models he should
just make it but it's going to be much
much tighter than previously expected I
think the final thing to note is that
you know we are living at the moment
through a cost of living crisis the
likes of which we really haven't seen in
living memory and what the bank is kind
of contributing to that is partly is
trying to bring down inflation but in
order to do that it is Raising interest
rates so now up to 4.5 percent those
interest rates take quite a while to
filter through into our pockets and you
know if you have a mortgage you're it
it's up to when you're refixing that
mortgage that you're going to start to
feel that pain and according to the bank
of England only about a third of that so
they put rates up it takes a while
before those households around the
country need to raise to refix their
mortgages and obviously suddenly go up
from maybe it was kind of one percent up
to four percent or even higher that's
taking a while to come through and only
according to the bank only about a third
of the pain from those Rising interest
rates has yet been felt so there is
still a lot of pain two-thirds of that
pain yet to come so there is a bit of
you know it's not necessarily going to
make this The Filling of the cost of
living crisis go away for many families
particularly around the country
particularly those who don't necessarily
have the savings built up from the
pandemic particularly those who are on
mortgages at the moment it's going to be
quite tough over the course of the next
few months but the bank does say the big
picture for the economy is considerably
less bad than it was before they're not
talking about recession they're very
happy that energy prices aren't quite as
high as they were previously and they
say that things certainly don't look as
bad as they were last time they looked
at the numbers so that is at least
something uh to take solace in
well yes so some positives there aired
but as you say the interest rate has
been raised have they given any hints
about whether that's the last one
well every time the bank raises interest
rates they obviously they announce the
decision you get kind of the the
determination about how many people on
the monetary policy committee because
it's essentially in that building there
is a policy Committee of nine people
that meets to decide these things this
time around it was a 7-2 vote so they
vote on it and we get the minutes and
then alongside the minutes you get a few
paragraphs that kind of provide a little
bit of a hint about what they might do
in future and in this case I suppose the
main point is that those paragraphs were
kind of the same as they were before and
previously they were saying basically if
things kind of carry on as we expect
them to carry on then we probably
shouldn't need to raise rates further
than the market current expects and the
market currently expects rates to go up
one more time so what we could be
looking at right now is we're very close
to the peak it could well be that
there's an extra increase but of course
you never know and it's worth just
bearing in mind that one of the things
that the bank has talked about today is
the fact that it's been taken uh by
surprise taken aback by how fast food
inflation is going up at the moment they
just didn't expect food prices to go up
so high and we all know again we are
paying those prices we're seeing that in
the supermarket every day well that's
looking at them and saying oh well maybe
they are going up a bit higher than we
expected a bit faster than we expected
and they might be going up a bit faster
next year as well so all of those things
would actually all EL secret put a bit
more pressure on the bank to raise
interest rates but as I say most people
in the markets think maybe one more
increase so you're getting to 4.75
the thing to note though okay is that
that might sound low in historic
comparison okay look back through
history and there were periods where
interest rates were up at like 10 double
digits even above that however in those
periods the level of debt that many
people had around the economy mortgage
people but those who had mortgages and
so on was smaller than it was it was
smaller than it is now so higher debt
the fact that we are slightly less able
less equipped with higher incomes to be
able to pay that debt means the squeeze
that you face from every one small
increase in interest rates is much
greater now than it was before so even
though it's four percent even though
it's 4.25 even though it's four and a
half percent as it has just gone up to
today that still has a bearing on many
households and what they're paying for
their mortgages that is similar to what
you saw in the 1980s and getting up
towards the 1990s so this is still
important stuff and it's still it's
still very painful for many households
indeed